alors maintenant ça se passe dans
l'espace pour regarder un film
évidemment on n'a pas de salle de cinéma
mais on regarde sur un rétroprojecteur
que qu'on a monté il y a quelques années
donc c'est pas un truc très récent on a
un écran qu'on a un peu bricolé c'est
des espèces de grandes feuilles de de
plastique blanc qu'on déploie comme
écran et on s'installe tous alors on
choisit un endroit en général un peu
confortable ou on tient plus on
s'installe dans quelques heures au
plafond il y en a quelques uns sur les
murs il y en a euh il faut se fixer en
fait parce que sinon tu flottes donc en
général on a des espèces de tendeur ou
des élastiques on se glisse dedans on
coince à pied etc on éteint les lumières
et puis on lance le film il y a un côté
qui est assez sympa et on
partage ces moments là ensemble c'est
souvent des films plutôt américain parce
que la langue la plus connue c'est c'est
l'anglais mais moi j'ai essayé de leur
montrer des films en français en
essayant un peu de faire la traduction
simultanée ou avec les Russes etc mais
c'est soit un moment assez sympa c'est
un des seuls loisirs qu'on a en commun à
bord de la Station spatiale